GOOD MORNING AND A WELCOME TO
THE LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEE AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE HEARING FOR
A APRIL THE TENTH -- WE HAVE --
TEN ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB -- SIX
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
IS ON CONSENT -- AND ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB ONE THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR JACKSON'S JACKSON HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THE HEARING
TODAY -- SO WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE SINCE WE DO NOT
HAVE OR HAVE NOT ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM SENATOR ROTH ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB THREE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SURE THIS IS THE LABOR COMMITTEE
IT ALWAYS WORKS -- MY FIRST TIME
IN FRONT OF YOU AND YOUR NEW
COMMITTEE -- AND I'M HONORED
THAT THAT GRADUATION THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO
THE SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY TWO
TODAY.
CURRENTLY THE LAW DOES NOT.
TO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT --
TO POST UNPAID WAGES DUE TO
EMPLOYEES FROM EMPLOYERS ON A
WEBSITE.
IN SOME CASES ALTHOUGH THERE'S
BEEN A DETERMINATION AND FORMER
EMPLOYEES DO MONEY.
FROM AN EMPLOYER THE EMPLOYEE
MAY NEVER LEARN OF IT AND NEVER
CLAIM THE MONEY.
SO WHAT THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES IS
A REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT TO
LIST ALL SUCH FUNDS ON A
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE WEBSITE.
THE WEBSITE WILL BE INDEXED BY
THE NAME OF THE EMPLOYEE THE
NAME OF THE EMPLOYER.
THE AMOUNT OF WAGES AND BENEFITS
AND THE DATE THEY WERE DEPOSITED --
IF WE THINK THIS IS A THE BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE THE WAGES THAT THERE DO
WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO ON THIS
BILL AND INTEND TO CONTINUE TO
WORK AT A LITTLE BIT TO A JUST A
JUST SOME OF THE PROVISIONS.
CHAIR BUT I WANT TO GO AHEAD
SENATE TODAY.
TO HOPEFULLY MOVE THIS ALONG
VERY GOOD I APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR ROTH AND AND SO I GUESS
IS A BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED THAT
YOU BE WORKING ON IT AND PERHAPS
AMENDMENTS AND WE CAN KICK OUT
OF THE LOOP.
GRANT THAT WE WE CAN.
BE THERE TO HELP AND MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS MOVE -- AS THEY
SHOULD WHAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
OF IS THAT WE CAPTURE OF
REPRESENTATIVE ACTIONS AND AND
AND CLASS ACTIONS IF APPROPRIATE.
WHERE EMPLOYEES ARE ALSO DO
MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE?
THE FORMER EMPLOYEES IN THE
WAGES DO ARE ALSO INCLUDED IN
THIS SO THAT ANY EMPLOYEE WHOSE
DO MONEY.
AS A RESULT OF A WAGE ACTION --
HAS THE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
THE EMPLOYEE'S NAME POSTED SO IF
THE EMPLOYEES NO LONGER EMPLOYED
THERE WHICH USUALLY IS THE CASE
OBVIOUSLY OR THEY WOULD RECEIVE
A CHECK.
THE EMPLOYEE CAN GO TO THE
WEBSITE FORMER EMPLOYEE CAN GO
TO THE WEBSITE FIND OUT WHAT'S
OWED.
CLAIM THE MONEY AND RECEIVE IT.
I LIKE IT.
OF THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
GOOD NEWS TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF FREE SHE ADDED SENATOR
ROTH THANK YOU WE WILL.
OBVIOUSLY HAVE THE VOTE -- WHEN
WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ON
[inaudible]
YEAH
WE A LITTLE BIT THAT TIME OF THE
YEAR.
THANK YOU
.
WE'RE SO HAPPY TO SEE YOU.
REMOVING THE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SB.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT IT'S SO GOOD TO
SEE YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU WELL I AM [inaudible]
HE SHE YOU'RE OUT REACH SO WE
COULD FILL THE GAP HERE --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING SENATE BILL.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT CURRENTLY THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO ASSESS UNPAID
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME WAGES.
THROUGH A CITATION ISSUED
AGAINST AN EMPLOYER IN OTHER
RESPONSIBLE INDIVIDUALS THE
CITATIONS MAY BE PROSECUTED
TOGETHER IN A SINGLE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDING WHEN
THE CITATIONS ARE APPEALED.
CONTRACT WAGES HOWEVER MAY BE
ENFORCED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ONLY THROUGH A
CIVIL ACTION FILED IN SUPERIOR
COURT.
VIOLATIONS OF THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND OVERTIME PAY REQUIREMENTS
ARE OFTEN ACCOMPANIED BY NON
PAYMENT OF CONTRACT WHICH IS.
OVER THE LABOR COMMISSIONER JUST
NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ASSESS
AND PROSECUTE CONTRACT WHICH IS
IN HIS UNABLE TO PROSECUTE
COMPANION CONTRACT WAGE
VIOLATIONS.
IN THE SAME ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEEDING AS MINIMUM WAGE AND
OVERTIME VIOLATIONS SENATE BILL
SIX EIGHT EIGHT GIVES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
THE AUTHORITY TO ASSESS UNPAID
CONTRACTUAL WAGES TO A CITATION
ISSUED AGAINST AN EMPLOYER.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE WORKERS
ARE PAID THEIR APPROPRIATE
CONTRACTUAL WAGES IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
BY PERMITTING I'M PAID CONTRACT
WAGES TO BE COLLECTED THROUGH
THE ISSUANCE OF CITATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME IN
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE WITH ME
WITNESSES. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
CSUS ARE DS WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND THEN FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE HAVE.
A DAVID BALTAR ASSISTANT CHIEF
COUNSEL WITH DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT AVAILABLE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS LINK
THANK YOU SENATOR MONEY A GREAT
BUILT BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PROCESS IDEA ARE
MEMBERS INCLUDING CENTER LINE.
YEAH.
WAIT STAFF IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY IS A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A HUGE IMPACT ON US
AND OUR CONTRACTORS ABILITY TO
COMPETE IN THAT ENVIRONMENT.
A STUDY IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REPORTED THAT HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WERE NOT REPORTED OR
WERE MISCLASSIFIED.
A 40% INCREASE SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO FAQ
INSTRUCTION WORKERS IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY -- AND HALF
OF WHAT PROPERLY REPORTED
WORKERS EARN IN A THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO LIVE IN POVERTY.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST CONSTRUCTION
LAST YEAR A REPORT BY THE
CORPORATE RESEARCH PROJECT OF
GOOD JOBS FIRST.
WAS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE SAN JOSE
MERCURY NEWS ARTICLE.
AS STATED THAT THE NINE WORKERS
FAIR WAGES IS PERVASIVE AND I
QUOTE FAR BEYOND SWEAT SHOPS
FAST FOOD OUTLETS AND RETAILERS.
THE AUTHOR OF THE REPORT STATED
THAT WASTE AFTER WAS AGAIN QUOTE
BUILT INTO THE BUSINESS MODEL OF
A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF
CORPORATE AMERICA.
WE SUPPORT SIX ADA BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S ENFORCEMENT IS
LACKING AS IT RELATES TO THE
WORLD CLASS ECONOMY THEY HEALTH.
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD WITH A WORKFORCE OF OVER
SEVENTEEN MILLION.
TWICE THE THE SIZE OF THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON NEEDS TO ADJUST AND
PROVIDE PROPER FORSMAN TOOLS TO
PREVENT THESE TYPES OF
VIOLATIONS AND WE ARE AT YOUR
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
IS OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
OBSERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
WITH A MAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHIRLA MEMBERSMUCH
DARKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU AGAR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO -- ONE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY
AND MINING FOR CURTIS AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND WILLINGNESS AND HIS
WILLINGNESS TO SPEAK WITH US ON
THIS ISSUE.
OUR CONCERNS ARE THAT THE LABOR
CODE PROVISION THAT IS AMENDED
ALLOWS FOR PERSONAL LIABILITY AS
WELL AS LIQUIDATED DAMAGES.
AND THIS IS PERSONAL LIABILITY
FOR ANYONE THAT IS INTRICATE
THAT IS INVOLVED WITH THE
PAYMENT OF WAGES FOR THE
EMPLOYEES WHICH INCLUDE HUMAN
RESOURCES PROFESSIONALS.
AS WELL AS AND MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS THIS CLAIM COULD
ALSO BE BROUGHT UNDER THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT SO
THEN YOU HAVE THOSE PENALTIES.
THAT WOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR THE
PERSONAL LIABILITY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
THOSE ARE MAIN CONCERNS WITH
REGARD TO AMENDING THIS SPECIFIC --
WAGE PROVISIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MR.
YES MISTER CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY
ON BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA BUILDS
ASSOCIATION WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE NUMERATOR BY
MISS CURTIS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR PAN.
NICE TO SEE YOU HERE THIS
MORNING.
GINGER COMMENT -- HOW HOW WOULD
YOU RESPOND TO THAT KATIE A
CHAMBERS CONCERNED ABOUT THE THE
LIABILITY RIGHT WELL FIRST OF
ALL WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES THAT'S A
CONTRACTUAL PROVISION SO IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT?
GETS CREATED IN THE ENFORCEMENT
SO IT'S BEEN AGREED TO IN A
CONTRACT IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
THERE WAS ANOTHER ELEMENT IN THE
CHAMBERS LETTER OF OPPOSITION --
THAT I DON'T THINK WAS
HIGHLIGHTED HERE BUT THE CONCERN
OF THE POTENTIAL ADDED BURDEN OF
SIT SIT DEPARTMENT LABOR CAN
ENFORCE.
MINIMUM WAGE OVERTIME PAY ET
CETERA BY ALLOWING THOSE
PROVISIONS FROM A CONTRACT TO BE
BROUGHT INTO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ARENA.
IN ACTUALLY IN MY VIEW WOULD
CONSOLIDATE ISSUES THAT COULD BE
DEALT WITH AT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LEVEL AND KEEP YOU OUT OF A A
SIMULTANEOUS COURT ENFORCEMENT --
I THINK IT'S IN THE INTEREST OF
BOTH SIDES TO CONSOLIDATE ANY
CLAIMS AND TRY TO DISPENSE WITH
THEM IN AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING.
INSTEAD OF CORD ALTOGETHER THAT
WOULD BE MY RESPONSE IN THE
QUESTION RELATED TO PERSONAL
LIABILITY FOR A HUMAN RESOURCES
PROFESSIONAL OR SOMEONE THAT
WOULD BE.
IS THAT.
I AM GONNA DIFFER I'M NOT SURE
THAT I FOLLOW THAT -- CONCERNS
DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT.
ACTUALLY IT IT THEN THAT'S FINE
I DID GET ANY ENTRY IT'S STILL
ALL TODAY AND APPLIES TO ANY
MINIMUM WAGE ENFORCEMENT ACTION
SO IT.
IT'S IT'S JUST ADDING IT TO THAT
PARTICULAR CONTRACTUAL CATEGORY.
YOUR USUAL FOR SOMEONE IN THE
ROLE OF A PERSONNEL MANAGER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO BE HELD.
LIABLE IT'S FOR SOMEONE WHO
CAUSES VIOLATION.
GENERALLY SPEAKING I MEAN FOR
MURDER FORSMAN STANDPOINT THE
AGENCIES LOOK LOOKING AT LARGELY
SMALL -- S. CORPORATION TYPE
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE REALLY IS
NO DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
THE THE CORPORATION AND THE
INDIVIDUAL OWNERS IN THEIR HANDS
ON INVOLVED IN MANAGING BUSINESS.
THANK OU COULD YOU SHOULD STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD SURE
INSIDE DAVID BALL TERM AN
ASSISTANT CHIEF COUNSEL WITH THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER --
VIEWED IT SINCEWE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM WE CAN ESTABLISH THAT AND
CAN'T TAKE A MOTION BUT WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE WILL.
OF CERTAINLY TAKE UP THE MATTER
WHEN THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
JUST AT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE IN
APPRECIATE YOUR ACCOMMODATING.
EVERYBODY SCHEDULES TODAY HAVE A
GOOD HEARING THANK YOU THANK YOU
CEREMONY WE WILL DO THAT
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
FORGET SENATOR GALGIANI GOOD
MORNING [inaudible]
PLEASE COME.
COME FORWARD THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB [inaudible]
FIVE GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME MORE TO MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
SB FIVE THIRTY WILL REQUIRE THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT TO DEVELOP AN
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION PREVENTION POLICY.
FOR USE BY EMPLOYERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
I'M GOING REVELATIONS UNDERSCORE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WIDESPREAD
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EXISTS WITHIN
VIRTUALLY EVERY INDUSTRY.
THESE INCIDENTS UNDERMINE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OUR STATE IS MADE
TOWARDS GENDER EQUITY IN THE
WORKPLACE.
HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED WOMEN
OF THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE AND
<c.blue>CONOMY.</c>
HOWEVER DESPITE EFFORTS TO
RECRUIT WOMEN INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WOMEN MAKE
THAT JUST EIGHT POINT 5%.
OF CALIFORNIANS TOLL
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE AND ONLY
3% OF THE APPRENTICES AND ROLLED
IN THE EMPRESS APPRENTICES
SHIPPED SYSTEM.
SB FIVE THIRTY ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP AN
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC ANTI
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
POLICY IN TRAINING STANDARD. FOR
USE BY CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS.
DIRECTLY ADDRESSING THE ON GOING
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
ISSUES ON THE JOB SITE WILL
ENSURE ALL WORKERS ARE TREATED
FAIRLY AND EQUALLY AND WILL HELP
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF THE
INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
OR WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
SB FIVE THIRTY CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE.
HELLO MEDIAN REDUCE MYSELF
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR HEARING
FROM US TODAY MY NAME IS MEGAN
MAY SEE.
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF TRADE
SOME IN INK I'M ALSO A FORTY
YEAR MEMBER OF IBEW LOCAL THREE
OH TWO AND GRADUATED FROM MY
PARTNERSHIP.
AND WORK WITH THE TOOLS FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS BEFORE I
GAVE IT UP FOR FLUSH TOILETS AND
A PHONE AND WITH THE LIGHTS
ALREADY IN THE BUILDING -- I
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING THIS
TODAY AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE NEED FOR
THIS KIND OF SPECIFIC TRAINING
AND WHY IT ISN'T.
JUST A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING OFF THE SHELF.
AND I SPEAK FROM MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE PLUS THE WOMEN THAT
WE WORK WITH TODAY.
ADDRESSING THE INDUSTRY ISSUES
HERE AND I'M ALSO VERY PLEASED
TO BE JOINED IN THIS WITH THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES WHO ARE HELPING US WITH
THIS ISSUE AND MOVE THE INDUSTRY
FORWARD -- AS A SENATOR GALGIANI
STATED WERE ONLY 3% OF THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES FOR WOMEN
WHO WORK WITH THE TOOLS THAT
NUMBERS ABOUT THE SAME -- THE
NOT THE 89% IS EVERYONE THAT
INCLUDES ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE'S WHO ARE THE DIRECT LINE
OF HIRE AND FIRE THE
DIFFERENT IN ITS HR PROCESSES
FROM OTHER INDUSTRIES.
YOU DON'T GO INTO THE OFFICE YOU
MAY NEVER SEE YOUR CONTRACTOR'S
OFFICE YOU MAY WORK THERE THREE
YEARS AND NEVER SEE THE
CONTRACTOR'S OFFICE.
IF YOUR RANK AND FILE WORKER YOU
A REPORT TO THE JOB SITE YOUR
DIRECT SUPERVISOR IS YOUR
FOREMAN.
AND OF THAT.
PERSON HAS THE RIGHT OF HIRE AND
FIRE OVER YOU YOUR TEMPORARY
WORKER.
THESE ARE IT'S A WONDERFUL
CAREER BUT IT COMES WITH A OF
WITH SOME DRAWBACKS PARTICULARLY
WHEN YOU ARE.
A WOMAN.
AND ONLY HAVE 3% YOU KNOW THE
YOU'RE LIKELY TO BE THE ONLY
WOMAN ON THAT JOB SITE.
WE ARE REALLY PLEASED TO BE
WORKING.
WITH THE INDUSTRY TO UPGRADE THE
CONDITIONS ON THE JOB SITE BUT
ONE OF THE MAJOR REASONS FOR
ATTRITION PARTICULARLY FOR WOMEN.
IS THE DIFFICULT CONDITIONS THAT
THEY DO A CONFRONT ON THE JOB
SITE AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT SB.
FIVE THIRTY IS A U. S.
SIGNIFICANT TOOL TO BRING
CONTRACTORS TO THE TABLE BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT CONTRACTORS HAVE
A VERY POSITIVE ROLE. TO PLAY
WITH THE TRUCK IN CREATING A
TRAINING THAT WILL ACTUALLY WORK.
ON THE JOB SITE AND NOT ONE
THAT'S GIVEN TO UPPER LEVEL
SUPERINTENDENTS.
ON THEIR YEARLY WE TREAT WE
THINK THAT DIFFERENCE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE MADE A STEP FORWARD
WITH C..
E. O. REQUIREMENTS AN
APPRENTICESHIP WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WOULD PARTNER VERY
NICELY WITH THAT WE ALSO BELIEVE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF
THE INDUSTRY SPECIFICITY.
OF OF THE ISSUES ON A
CONSTRUCTION SITE THAT THIS IS
NOT A D. F. E. H..
FROM CONCERN IT'S REALLY A
DEALER SEE CONCERN BECAUSE IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE SPECIFIC
SPECIFICITY OF THE INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE THE D. L. L. C. ALREADY
DEALS WITH APPRENTICESHIP IN IN
AND OF OVERSIGHT A PREVAILING
WAGE IT HAS AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WHICH
IS NOT AVAILABLE ELSEWHERE.
WE ALSO REALLY AND WHEN YOU ARE
THIS MUCH OF A MINORITY IN A IN
A IN AN INDUSTRY.
YOU ARE NOT REALLY IN A POSITION
TO HAVE A PLAINTIVE DRIVEN
PROCESS THIS IS WHY WE'RE
WORKING REALLY CAREFUL CAREFULLY
AND WITH OUR PARTNERS AND WANT
TO BRING CONTRACT CONTRACTORS TO
THE TABLE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE.
A FULL COURT PRESS WITH ALL THE
IMPORTANT PEOPLE AT THE TABLE
ALL THE IMPORTANT IN INTEREST AT
THE TABLE. TO MAKE IT BETTER
WORK SITE CULTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WHAT WAS YOUR MEMBERS -- I KEEP
CANNOT BE MORE ELOQUENT THAN
THAT THAT WAS A PERFECT
TESTIMONY YOU JUST WANNA SAY
THAT UP THE SECOND TIME WE RUN
THE LEGISLATION.
OF FOR THE REASONS THAT MAKE
BASS HE STATED -- WHY IT'S
BETTER SUITED AT THE I. R.
VERSUS THE FE H. ON WE ARE
TRYING TO AND FROM THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP MODEL ALL THE WAY
UP TO THE A PARTNERSHIP THAT WE?
OF PASSAGE LEGISLATION -- IN CO
SPONSORSHIP WITH -- TRADE WOMEN
THANK LAST YEAR THIS BUILDS UPON
THAT AND LOOKS AT THE
CONSTRUCTION SPECIFIC POLICY.
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
CREATED BETTER WORK ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL EVERY EVERY WORKER ON
THE CONSTRUCTION WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE HIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS
AND CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CENTERS THOSE SERVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF WITH A MAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
AN ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
THANK CHIRLA MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SHOULD CHECK YOUR GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
WE CAN BRING IT BACK TO THE TO
THE COMMITTEE AND WE HAVE LOOKS
LIKE WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SHOW IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
SENATOR HILL DEAR SENATOR HILL
HERE MORRELL.
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL HERE PAT.
YEAH PAN HERE.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE
DIDN'T AND WE DO HAVE A
PROMOTION COMING IN AND I THINK
THIS IS THIS IS A GREAT.
DEAL THE GREAT BILL AND AND AND
I THINK TIMELY BUT THIS IS KIND
OF FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR BILL
SENATOR MITCHELL FROM LAST YEAR.
THAT -- TRIES TO IN THE IS THE
CONCERN OF THE QUESTION THAT WAS
RAISED IS THAT THE TRAINING YOU
KNOW ONCE THIS THIS TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD COME UNDER
THAT -- IT BE NICE TO BE ABLE TO
THEN HAVE WHATEVER EVALUATION
FROM A COMMISSION TO LOOK AT THE
EFFECT OF THAT IN THE BENEFITING
WEATHERED ACTUALLY IS WORKING.
AND AND A TV IN THAT SHOW OF
MAYBE A LITTLE TIME.
SPREAD BEFORE THAT THAT STARCH
AND CAN CAN LOOK AT THAT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE AND WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT OR LOOK AT THE FUTURE
BUT I DO THINK THIS IS A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY.
TO KIND OF FOLLOW UP ON THAT
GOOD LEGISLATION FROM LIFE I
WOULD AGREE AND AND AND
APPRECIATE THE VALUATION BUT I
THINK THE ULTIMATE TEST IS WHEN
THE CULTURE SHIFT IN WORK SPACES
ACROSS THIS STATE AND COUNTRY
AND AND AND WOMEN.
AND MEN FEEL AND EXPERIENCE THAT
DIRECTLY THAT'S THE ULTIMATE
TEST OF SUCCESS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE BUT I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL VERY GOOD THANK
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE THE
SENATE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MITCHELL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS HILL I FEEL I'M
RURAL.
MITCHELL.
HI MITCHELL AYE POUND RIGHT PAN
I HAVE THREE THREE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE WILL CONTRAPTION
MEMBRANE A VERY MUCH.
WONDERFUL.
CENTER STRINGENT IS WAY DOWN AND
I THINK I WILL PRESENT IF IT
WORKS ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN I WILL TURN THE
GAVEL SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU ATWATER CHAIRING BOTH --
LABOR AND PURRS BEFORE A TO GET
STILL LEVEES HAVE THE DEVIL HERE
OKAY -- SO WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING I ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS AND EXCELLENT COMMITTEE --
AS DISCUSSED IN THE ANALYSIS
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORKS OR M.
P. ENDS ARE A KEY TOOL IN OUR
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM. TO
ENSURE THAT INJURED WORKERS GET
THE TREATMENT THEY NEED IN A
COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
M. PEONS ALSO ENSURE THAT
WORKERS HAVE ENOUGH CHOICE TO
ACCESS MEDICAL CARE WITH
PROVIDERS THEY ARE COMFORTABLE
TO SEE.
HOWEVER MORE AND MORE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE STEPPED
FORWARD WITH CONCERNS ON HOW IN
PEONS ARE OPERATING IN THIS
STATE SPECIFICALLY.
THE CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION REPORTS THAT SOME IN
PEONS ARE PLACING PROFITS BEFORE
CARE.
AS WE DOCUMENTED IN A RECENT
LAWSUIT C. P. T. A. WITH HAS
SHOWN MULTIPLE INSTANCES OF
PHYSICAL THERAPIST BEING PUSHED.
TO TAKE LOWER AND LOWER
REIMBURSEMENTS FREQUENTLY BY
REVEALING THAT NEIGHBORING PT'S
HAVE AGREED TO LOWER RATES.
THIS RACE TO THE BOTTOM DRIVES
PT'S OUT OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM HURTING BOTH
INJURED WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
TRYING TO RETURN THEIR INJURED
WORKERS TO WORK.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THIS RACE TO THE BOTTOM BY
SETTING THE MEDICARE FEE
SCHEDULE AS THE MINIMUM
REIMBURSEMENT HALTING THE RIGHT
THE REYES.
THE RACE TO THE BOTTOM
ADDITIONALLY SB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN ADDRESSES TO OTHER ISSUES
RAISED BY C. P. T. A. M. P. AND
N..
M. P. ENDS CHANGING A MEDICAL
PROVIDER TREATMENT PLANS AND
MEDICAL BILLING CODES WITHOUT
CONSULTING WITH A PHYSICIAN OR
MEDICAL PROVIDER.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PROHIBITS
SUCH CHANGES WITHOUT FIRST
CONSULTING WITH A PHYSICIAN OR
PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
ATTHIS TIME -- WOULD LIKE TO
ASK A DOCTOR RICH A RICK KATZ
CHAIR OF THE PAYMENT POLICY
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION.
AND STEVE -- CATOLICA WITH THE
INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL THERAPIST
OF CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF SB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN JENNER HELL WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER HEALTH.
APPRECIATE THE INTRODUCTION ON
THE BILL -- MY NAME IS RICK
KATIMA DOCTOR PHYSICAL THERAPY
AND A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION.
I'M ALSO A BUSINESS OWNER FOR A
PHYSICAL THERAPY CLINICS IN
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN INCLUDES
PROVISIONS THAT CORRECT LOOP
HOLES IN IT THE EXISTING LAWS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN SB EIGHT
SIXTY THREE ONE A LONG WAY
TOWARDS.
CORRECT IN ISSUES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL MEDICAL
FEE SCHEDULE AND ENCOURAGING
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS TO RE
ENTER THE MARKET AND PROVIDE
QUALITY OF CARE TO THE INJURED
WORKER.
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED THE WIDELY
USED OUR B. R. B. S. SYSTEM AND
ALSO ADOPTED THE NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OCCUPATIONAL BY MENTAL MEDICINE
GUIDELINES WHICH ESTABLISHED
PARAMETERS FOR DETERMINING
MEDICAL NECESSITY AND
APPROPRIATE REALIZATION.
HOWEVER OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
HAS BEEN AN INFLUX OF ENTITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE FOUND AN
OPPORTUNITY CREATE NARAL
NETWORKS THE RESULT IN CARE
BEING DRIVEN TO THE LOWEST COST
PROVIDER SNL ILLUSTRATED.
AND WITH WITHOUT REGARD TO THE
QUALITY OF CARE.
THESE DISCOUNTS HAD DRIVEN THE
MARKET DOWN TO A POINT WHERE
PROVIDERS ARE ONCE AGAIN
DISCOURAGED FROM PARTICIPATING
IN THE WORKERS COMP ARENA.
IN ADDITION THESE ENTITIES WHICH
OUT CALL MIDDLEMAN OR THIRD
PARTY PARTY NON ACCREDITED
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
CONSISTENTLY INTERFERE WITH THE
TREATMENT PLAN DEVELOPED BY THE
TREATING PHYSICIAN.
AND PHYSICAL THERAPIST THE
SETTING ASIDE THE STATE ADOPTED
A CALM GUIDELINES.
NETWORKS ARE ACTUALLY LISTED AS
THE ACTUAL PHYSICAL THERAPIST
INSTEAD OF THE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST THEMSELVES ON THE N.
P. AND DIRECTORIES ELIMINATING
THE ABILITY FOR A PHYSICIAN TO
SELECT THE DOWNSTREAM PROVIDER
OF CHOICE WITHIN THAT NETWORK.
NETWORK TRANSPARENCY IN THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE.
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW BUT DOES
NOT EXIST IN WORKERS COPY ON THE
LISTING OF THE PHYSICIAN AND A
NETWORK.
FINALLY THESE NETWORKS HAVE BEEN
FOUND TO TAKE BILLS SUBMITTED TO
THEM BY PROVIDERS.
AND RE PRICE THE CLAIMS IN ORDER
TO INCREASE THEIR OWN BOTTOM
LINE PROFITS. TO THE PRACTICES
OF THESE NETWORKS HAVE GONE AS
FAR AS TO PIT ONE PROVIDER
AGAINST ANOTHER WITH.
WHICH WITH THREATS THAT PATIENTS
WILL BE RE DIRECTED TO THE
COMPETITOR IF THEY DO NOT ACCEPT
LOWER RATES.
AND DECREASED THEIR UTILIZATION
THESE ACTIVITIES OCCUR WITHOUT
THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE EMPLOYER.
AND RESULT IN DELAYED ACCESS TO
CARE FOR THE INJURED WORKER.
THE NETWORK NEGOTIATE THE PRICE
OF THE CARRIER THAN DISCOUNT
SURPRISED TO THE PROVIDER AND
KEEP THE SPREAD.
DRIVING DOWN THE PRICE TO
PROVIDE. TO THE PROVIDER ONLY
BENEFITS THAT MIDDLEMAN ENTITY
AND ADDS NO VALUE TO THE
EMPLOYER OR THE INJURED WORKER
AND DELAYED ACCESS TO CARE IS
PROVEN TO RESULT IN HIGHER
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYER DANITY COSTS.
SO THESE PRACTICES RESULT IN IN
A FEDERAL LAWSUIT WHICH MISTER
KIND OF CALL AGAIN -- ELABORATE
ON BETWEEN INDEPENDENT GROUP OF
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND ONE SUCH
ENTITY THAT EXPOSED A WEAKNESS
THE CALIFORNIA LAWS.
THE LAWSUIT RESULTED IN A
SETTLEMENT TO CURTAIL SOME OF
THESE ACTIVITIES OF ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUAL ENTITIES FOR DEFINED
PERIOD OF TIME BUT DID NOTHING
TO STOP OTHERS FROM FOLLOWING
THE SAME PRACTICES.
SO ONE OF THE PURPOSES OF FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN IS TO CURTAIL THESE
BAD BEHAVIORS REINFORCE EXISTING
LAW WORK IS NEEDED.
IT ALSO PROMOTES THE ABILITY OF
THE ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE D. I. R. TO EXERCISE THEIR
AUTHORITY FOR INVESTIGATION AND
ENFORCEMENT.
SO WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR HILL
FOR HIS ADDRESSING THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES ENERGY TO
SUPPORT.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR SAYS
STEVE CATHOLIQUE I REPRESENT IN.
INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
OF CALIFORNIA -- ORGANIZATION IS
COMPRISED OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED PHYSICAL THERAPY
PRACTICES IN ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
LOCATIONS IN THE PROVIDE CARE --
TO ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW PATIENTS EVERY EVERY YEAR.
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HIS AUTHORSHIP OF FIVE SB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN AS WELL AS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO ITS
PASSAGE.
AMONG ITS IMPORTANT PROVISIONS
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THE LEGISLATURE'S AND ORIGINAL
INTENT.
WHEN PASSING SB EIGHT SIXTY
THREE IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND
SB ELEVEN SIXTY IN?
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN REINFORCES THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT.
IN EIGHT SIXTY THREE THAT ALL
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND EMPLOYERS
WHO PAY THEIR BILLS.
HAVE AN EFFICIENT METHOD TO
RESOLVE REIMBURSEMENT DISPUTE.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ASSURE CITY
INDEPENDENT BILL REVIEW PROCESS
CANNOT BE SIDE STEPPED OR
ELIMINATED.
BY PROVIDER NETWORKS THAT
SUBSTITUTE THEIR OWN
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION FOR
THE OUT OF THE REAL PROVIDER.
ON THE PROVIDERS BILL.
THIS NETWORK MANEUVER
DISCONNECTS THE REAL PROVIDER
FROM THE SECOND BILL REVIEW AN
INDEPENDENT BILL REVIEW SYSTEM.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN REINFORCES
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT WITH SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY THAT ONLY THE
EMPLOYERS URAC ACCREDITED
UTILIZATION REVIEW PROCESS.
THE ONE THAT'S REGISTERED WITH
THE DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DELAY DENY OR MODIFY MEDICAL
CARE THAT -- AND IT DOES SO BY
ASSURING THAT THE PROVIDER
NETWORKS CANNOT DELAY OR
MODIFYING AUTHORIZATION OF CARE
ALREADY OBTAINED BY THE
EMPLOYERS ACCREDITED.
PLAN.
WHY SUCH CLEAR LEGISLATION A
LEGISLATIVE INTENT EVEN NEEDING
REINFORCEMENT?
ON THESE ISSUES ARE ORGANIZATION
AS DR KATZ MENTIONED.
THE INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS WON A LAWSUIT IN
FEDERAL COURT AGAINST A MAJOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION DISCOUNT
NETWORK IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SOME OF
THE EVIDENCE THAT -- PROVIDED.
PROVED THAT THE ALLEGATIONS ARE
PREDATORY PRICE PRICING IN
CONTRACTING.
ILLEGAL PATIENTS STEERAGE
INTERFERENCE WITH PROVIDER
PATIENT RELATIONSHIP EXISTED
[inaudible]
IN SHORT.
THE EROSION OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENTION IN ACTING MANY OF
THOSE REFORMS. FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU MAY REMEMBER IN SB EIGHT
SIXTY THREE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A NEW AMERICAN MEDICAL FEE
SCHEDULE FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION BASED ON THE SAME
SCHEDULE USED. FOR THE NATIONAL
MEDICARE SYSTEM.
THE PURPOSE AND INTENT.
WERE WERE TO ESTABLISH A
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM BOTH
PREDICTABLE FOR EMPLOYERS.
AS WELL AS FAIR TO THE IN
MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN REINFORCES
THAT INTENT BY PREVENTING
NETWORKS FROM ARBITRARILY
CHANGING BILLING CODES.
AND UNBUNDLING PROCEDURES
THEREBY INFLATING THE BILL
CHARGES.
IT ALSO CURTAILS ILLEGAL
PREDATORY NETWORK CONTRACTING
PRACTICES.
THE PRESS PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT
RATES SOMETIMES WELL BELOW
MEDICARE.
WHILE FEE SCHEDULE REIMBURSEMENT
AND THE MODIFIED BILL CHARGES GO
UP.
YOU'VE BEEN PROVIDED WITH THE
GRAPH THAT ILLUSTRATES THIS
POINT.
AFTER PASSAGE OF S. S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY THREE AS TIME WENT BY.
THE SPREAD BETWEEN CONTRACTED
REIMBURSEMENT DEPICTED BY THE
FLAT LINE REIMBURSEMENT A
TYPICAL SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
VISIT.
AND THE RISING OWN FS
REIMBURSEMENT INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY.
TURNOUTS DETECTED BY THE BLUE
LINE.
EXTRA CASH YOU TO TRY TO WRAP UP
JORDAN.
I CAN'T.
HEAR THE EMPLOYER CONTINUES TO
PAY THE UPPER FEE.
BUT CERTAINLY THE NETWORK
BENEFITS BY THE SPREAD.
EVIDENCE IS PRACTICE ALSO WAS
PART OF THE RECENT LAWSUIT.
WHY WOULD DIE PROVIDERS NEED TO
GO TO FEDERAL COURT?
SB FIVE SIXTY THREE ASSURES THAT
INJURED WORKERS WELL I WILL NOT
HAVE -- TO BE PUT THROUGH THIS.
AND IN IN ADDITION IS DR KATZ
MENTIONED WILL PROVIDE THEM WITH
CLEAR A CLEAR CHOICE WHEN --
ASKING FOR PROVIDERS OUT OF THE
NETWORK.
SB FIVE THIRTY SIX PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INJURED WORKERS BY
PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY.
PERMANENTLY FIXING PREDATORY
PRICING -- SCHEMES AND INSURING
APPROPRIATE YOU ARE PROCESSES.
I COULD GO ON I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
WE HAVE QUESTIONS I'M SURE WE
WILL ASK THEM AND I I BELIEVE
THERE'S NO FORMAL OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL SO I THINK YOU'RE IN
GOOD SHAPE.
AT OTHER WITNESSES AND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES OUT ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
RULES THE TAIL AT THEIR THE BEST
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED --
CENTER HELLO.
AND I WILL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ADAM
SECRETARY THE BILL'S BEEN DISS
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BUILT A NEW
BY SIR MITCHELL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HELLO HI PHIL HI
MORALE.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL FIVE I PATH I HAVE A
GOOD MORNING AGAIN WE ARE MOVING
TO ITEM NUMBER. THREE FOUR
THIRTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE COMMITTEES.
I MENTIONED CAN THINK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THE FILM
[inaudible] FOR SB.
FOUR THIRTY TELL THE CORRECTION
NAM IN THAT AS TO MY KNOWLEDGE
AFFECTS ONLY NINE JUDGES.
THESE NINE JUDGES CAME FROM
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND FILED RAN
AND WON THE RESPECTIVE OFFICES
AND IN TWENTY TWELVE MOST OF
THEM ONE IN JUNE BEFORE WE
ENACTED.
TRACK CHANGES.
THEN THEY GOT ELECTED IN
NOVEMBER AND THEN THEY DIDN'T
GETS WELLNESS ONE UNTIL JANUARY
THEY WERE UNABLE TO BE SWORN IN
BEFORE JANUARY. TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOR FOR PENSION PURPOSES AND
THEY HAVE BEEN TREATED DIFFER
PENSION PURPOSE THEY'VE BEEN
TREATED DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
OTHER JUDGES WHO WERE POINTED IN
TWENTY TWELVE BECAUSE THEY
HAPPEN TO HAVE.
BEEN COMING IN FROM THE PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SECTORS PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
PENSION REFORM ACT KNOWN AS
PEPPER ON WOULDN'T AFFECT AND
THAT AND JANUARY ONE AND
THEREFORE THEY MIX MR DEADLINES
THIS BILL SIMPLY.
REQUIRES AN EQUALIZATION OF THE
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE JUDGES RETIREMENT SYSTEM
FOR THESE FOR A NEW JUDGES BUT
THIS CHANGE -- APPROXIMATELY
DOUBLE THE JUDGES CONTRIBUTION
THESE NINE JUDGES AND THEIR
RETIREMENT SYSTEM FROM A PERCENT
260% WITH NO BENEFIT INCREASES.
SB FOUR THIRTY CLARIFY SAID
THESE NINE JUDGES AND THIS IS
ONLY THESE NINE JUDGES THIS IS
NOT.
THAT CAN'T MULLIN THE TENT
ANALOGY.
WHO WERE ELECTED DURING TWENTY
TWELVE BUT NOT TAKING OFFICE IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN ARE NOT NEW
JUDGES AS SET FORTH IN THE AN
ANALYSIS FOR PURPOSES OF THE
JUDGES RETIREMENT SSTEM?
THE STANDARDIZES THE TREATMENT
ALL JUDGES ELECTED AND OR
POINTER DURING. TO TWENTY TWELVE
FOR PURPOSES OF PEPPER AND WITH
YOUR HAVE MY BLOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE TEXAS ASSOCIATION.
RETURN MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MIKE FOLLOWED ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION I
KNOW MEANT ALL OF THE MEMBERS
HERE.
MAY REFER.
IN A VETO BY GOT THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN WE RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
THAT IT WAS CHIPPING AWAY AT
PEPPER.
WE SIMPLY THOUGHT IT WAS A
EQUITABLE A CLARIFICATION THAT
EVERYONE ALAC DID OR APPOINTED
IN.
TWENTY TWELVE WAS SUBJECT TO THE
OLD RULES I THINK THAT THE
ANALYSIS IS VERY FAIR AND
RAISING THE ISSUES AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT PENSIONS ARE.
SENSITIVE AND THAT YOU HAVE A
REAL DUTY TO THE PEOPLE TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT PENSION ISSUES --
AS CENTER WHAT KOWSKI NOTED
THERE THIS IS AN ANOMALY.
THIS IS THE ONLY GROUP THAT I'M
AWARE OF THAT HAS TO PASS THIS
TO OTHER POSITION MOST JUDGES
TAKE OFFICE BY APPOINTMENT.
AND THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
APPOINTED IN TWENTY TWELVE TOOK
OFFICE IN.
TWENTY IT IS THESE FEW PEOPLE
WHO WERE ELECTED AND BY THE WAY
ELECTION -- TO JUDGESHIPS HAS
BEEN THE PATH IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF OUR SYSTEM IT HAS
BEEN THE PATH.
WHERE PEOPLE OF UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS?
THE OTHER PARTY PUBLIC DEFENDERS
HAVE ACHIEVED JUDGESHIPS BY
ELECTIONS WHEN THEY OTHERWISE
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO BUT THESE
FEW PEOPLE.
COULDN'T TAKE OFFICE UNTIL THE
FIRST MONDAY OF JANUARY BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO VACANCY UNTIL THEN
SELL THE LEGISLATURE I BELIEVE --
APPROPRIATELY DECIDED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THAT IT WAS FAIR TO
TREAT THEM UNDER THE LAW THAT
EXISTED WHEN THEY FILE FOR
OFFICE RAN FOR OFFICE AND WON
THE OFFICE WHEN THEY COULDN'T
POSSIBLY HAVE KNOWN ANYTHING
ABOUT PEPPER.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
A UNIQUE CASE BECAUSE OF THE
APPOINTMENT ELECTION -- PARADOX
SO WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- AND
WOULD ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
MISTER BELOW OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
VERY GOOD WHY IS IT DIDN'T SET
IT QUESTIONS ABOUT YES MITCHELL
AND ANSWERED.
MY THANK YOU SARAH KOWSKI -- FOR
A PRESENTATION.
IS THAT RIGHT YEAH A STE STILL
HAVE I I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS --
SO I RECOGNIZE THIS IS A
SOMEWHAT YOU THE CASE FOR A VERY.
NARROW NUMBER -- WHICH DATE.
WHAT ELECTION CYCLE WHERE THESE
JUDGES ELECTED TWENTY TWELVE
TWENTY TWELVE AND?
AT NOVEMBER RIGHT A JUNE AND A
FRIEND WERE SPOTTED OUT HERE.
VIRTUALLY ALL WERE ELECTED IN
JUNE THERE WAS A COUPLE THAT
WENT TO RUN OFF OKAY -- YEAH AND
IT'S IT'S A SMALL NUMBER BUT AS
SOMEONE WHO YOU KNOW IT'S
OBVIOUSLY BEEN -- MONITORING AND
WHICH AND FIGHTING TO BE SURE WE
PROTECT OUR PENSION -- PROMISES
TO PLAYS AND AND EXTREMELY
SENSITIVE. TO TO ENSURE THE
UNDER MY REALIZE IS A SMALL
GROUP ADDRESS ACTIVE YOU KNOW --
BUT I AT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN THEY PASS UP FOR A THAT
THAT TIME DID NOT SPECIFICALLY
MAKE ANY EXEMPTION AYE AND SENT
TO THE NOW SISTERS OF THE
LAWSUIT THAT'S ON GOING I MEAN
DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING -- WE'RE LAWMAKERS --
BUT AT YEAH I AM I'VE MET HIM
[inaudible] TO CHIP WELL YOU
KNOW TO TO MAKE A SERVICES.
I MEAN EXEMPTIONS ARE EXEMPTION
RIGHT AND SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW
I I I AM ABLE TO AT LEAST VOTE
FOR THE BILL AT THIS TIME I
THINK THE THE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT BY BY ACTUALLY TAKING AN
EXEMPTION GIVEN.
EXCEPTION TO TIP WE'VE.
OVERTURNING.
THOSE OF US IN LOSS SIDE OF IT
VERSUS OVERTURNING AYE AYE CASE
AND JUST SAYING NO THIS IS A
CLARIFICATION -- THE TREATMENT
OF THESE FOLKS IT'S YOU CAN'T
HARPER.
I KNOW WELL.
HI THIS OTHER THAN SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO BE SWORN IN JANUARY.
THE DISK MOST WAS THE PEOPLE IT
WAS FAIR AGAIN AYE AYE WE WERE
HERE IN TWENTY TWELVE AND WE
WERE DEBATING THIS AFTER THEY
HAD WON THE ELECTION.
THEY WANT THEIR ELECTION THEY
WERE REYES TAKE SEE THEM WE SAY
OH NO WE'RE CHANGING THE RULES
SO IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM THAT
POINT OF VIEW IT'S IT'S FOR THE
BELT.
AS WE CAN DISABLE NO THAT'S WOOD
CHIPS FELL BUT IT WAS JUST
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF JUDGES.
NOT FILLING VACANCIES BY WAY.
THERE WERE VACANCIES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE THE GOVERNOR WOULD NOT
BUILD.
THESE WITH THESE PEOPLE THAT ONE
SO IS IT A DOUBLE WHAMMY UNDER
JUST IN THE WAY THAT THE COURTS
TO SEE PEOPLE SO WHICH LOVE YOUR
INTEREST IN A LAW FIRM YOU'VE.
RESIGNED FROM THE NONPROFIT
WHATEVER IT IS IT'S A
PARTICULARLY FINAL KINDS OF KIND
OF THING THAT PEOPLE DO WHEN
THEY WHEN THESE JUDGE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU AND IN A I I
WOULD AGREE WITH THE THE
ANALYSIS AND CERTAINLY WITH THE
THE COMMENT TO ME THIS IS AN
ANOMALY AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THIS
IS NOT PRESIDENT SETTING.
AN ON THE RECORD THAT WE KNOW
THAT BECAUSE OF THE ELECTION
TIMING AND BECAUSE OF WHEN.
SOMEONE TAKES OFFICE -- IT DID
CREATE A UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY WOULD HAVE
CHANGED THEIR MIND AFTER THE
ELECTION AND AN HOUR AFTER
PREPARA BUT THE POINT IS THAT
WAS IN THE ORIGINAL DEAL AND
WE'VE WE'VE.
KIND OF DONE THAT WITH ALL OF
OUR EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T CHANGE THE RULES AFTER --
FOR RETIREMENT AND WE'VE WE'VE
NOT DONE THAT AND IN MANY CASES
SO I THINK IT'S A IT'S AN HONEST
AND AND FAIR.
APPROACH AND AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT EIGHT EIGHT INDIVIDUALS
AND AND YOU'VE MADE IT CLEAR.
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU THAT
THIS ONLY APPLIES TO THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE THE ELECTION WAS
PRIOR TO THE THE EPUB OF
MEANINGFUL VIA COME INTO PLAY
ARE BECOMING LAW.
AND I THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
THING TO DO SO I APPRECIATE THAT
WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM A
SENATOR MITCHELL DIRECTOR LEVEL
CLOSE IN NO WE DO WE WANT TO
SPEAK.
PRESIDENT'S HEADING FOR ANY
OTHER SORT OF SUCH AS STATE --
EMPLOYEE AND IT'S NARROWLY
TAILORED WE WE BELIEVE -- TO
PROVIDE SOME FAIRNESS IS A NON
ANOMALY THAT HAS OCCURRED AND I
URGE AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR Y. CASKEY --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WITH SENATE
A MOTION FROM CENTER MITCHELL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS HILL HI HELLO I'M
LAURA.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE.
IF TO TO LOS WILL HOLD WILL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
OPEN THE ROLE IN ITEMS
APPROPRIATIONS HILL AYE.
AYE MORRELL.
JACKSON MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
AYE PAN. THREE VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS REMOVED ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB -- FIVE THIRTY WE HAVE A
MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION FROM THE
CENTER.
EXACTLY.
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
WE ARE DIFFERENT.
GALGIANI WE DID.
ARE YOU WERE I'M SORRY ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX EIGHTY
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE WE HAVE A
MOTION.
FOR THIS. SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE JUST -- DOCTOR FAMILY
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
SIX EIGHTY PLEASE CALL THE
OPTION.
HELLO HI I'M MORALE.
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE [inaudible]
AND GOOD THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OF RUSSIA MEMBERS
SENATOR STERN WELCOME I DON'T
NUMBER SIX SB.
FIVE FORTY TWO ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
NICE PLACE YOU THIS MORNING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
REMINDING ME ON THAT.
HERE COME ON THE RIGHT THERE
[inaudible]
THEIR SIGNATURE [inaudible] TO
HIM.
HE'S THE MAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THIS ONE'S HAVING -- THIS IS THE
IT'S A BILL ABOUT.
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE DIGEST WILL TELL YOU --
THIS IS ABOUT AT TOUGH MATERIAL
THAT -- PEOPLE DON'T OFTEN LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT -- WE ARE SEEING
SUICIDE RATES AMONG FIRST
RESPONDERS WRIT LARGE EXCEEDING --
YES ON THE FRONT LINES
THEMSELVES WE'RE TALKING A VERY
DANGEROUS JOBS TODAY AMONG PEACE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ALL KINDS OF TRAUMA -- NOT JUST
THE THE THE WILD FIRES AND THE
SORT OF STRESSORS THAT ARE RIGHT
IN OUR FACES BUT EVEN.
THE DAILY TRAGEDIES THAT YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH AS A POLICE
OFFICER OR FIREFIGHTER WHEN.
KID GETS KILLED ON THE STREET
AND WHAT IT'S LIKE.
A YOUNG MAN OFF OF SIDEWALK
WHO'S BEEN HIT BY A CAR LIKE IT
WAS THE OTHER DAY A BICYCLIST IN.
KOREA TOWN OR IN YOUR DISTRICT --
YOU KNOW THE FOLKS WHO WENT UP
AND FOUGHT THAT CAMPFIRE FOR
MONTHS ON END IN ITS IT.
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED -- TO
REARRANGE OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM I THINK THE
ANALYSIS FAIRLY POINTS OUT THAT
THIS DOES PUT A THUMB ON THE
SCALE.
OF BY SAYING THAT WE ARE GOING
TO PRESUME.
IF YOU ARE PEACE OFFICER -- WHO
IS REPORTING A POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS INJURY?
THAT OUR PRESUMPTION IS THAT WE
BELIEVE.
AND THAT THAT RESENT THE
PRESUMPTION IS REBUTTABLE.
BUT THAT THE LEVEL OF COURAGE IN
THE CURRENT DETERRENT.
OUT THERE BUILT INTO THE CULTURE
AROUND THIS KIND OF WORK.
IMPEDE THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO
STEP UP AND SHARE THE STORIES
THAT YOU HEAR.
SOME OF TODAY -- HAVING TO PROVE
YOUR CASE AND HAVING THE BURDEN
ON YOU. TO SAY THAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA THAT I'M
HAVING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS THAT
I'M GOING THROUGH SOMETHING THAT --
MAKES IT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NOT A LOT
OF FOLKS WANT TO ADMIT.
AND THAT'S CAUSING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS WE FEEL LIKE
WITHIN OUR RANKS -- AND WE'RE
SEEING IT IT'S IT'S BEEN
INTIMATELY KNOWN TO ME YOU KNOW.
THAT.
PARENTS OF YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE TAKING THEIR OWN LIVES
KITTEN VENTURA COUNTY IT ABOUT A
MONTH OR TWO AGO -- YOU KNOW
THIS IS GOTTEN PERSONAL SO I'LL
I'LL STEP OUT OF THE WAY AND I I
DO WANT TO ENGAGE IN THE POLICY
ISSUES HERE BECAUSE I THINK THEY
ARE IMPORTANT ONES I DO
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS BUT
RATHER THAN BELABOR THIS.
I'LL JUST SAY -- IT IS SAID IT
IS JUST THAT IT IS A THUMB ON
THE SCALE WE ARE AS A
LEGISLATURE WITH THIS BILL
SAYING.
IF YOUR SAYING YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH PTS AYE.
THE PRESUMPTION OUGHT TO BE WITH
YOU AND THAT WE CAN AFFORD TO
PAY THAT PRICE AND WE OUGHT TO
STEP UP AND PAY THAT PRICE IS
STATE.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THESE PEOPLE DO
THIS EVERY DAY SO AS FOR RIVAL.
SENATOR STERN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR ORNING MR
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTY BOMB ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE
AND IT'S MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE
ONE OF MY MEMBERS.
A DEREK ROBINSON'S A FIRE
CAPTAIN OF KERN COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
INTRODUCTION -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY.
I'M HERE PERSONALLY -- TO TELL
MY STORY.
I'M.
OF LIVING WITH AND RECOVERING
FROM PTS I MYSELF AFTER EIGHTEEN
YEARS ON THE JOB.
YOU CAN NOT.
GET RID OF THE TRAUMA THAT IS IN
PLEASE NON YOUR HEART MIND AND
SOUL AFTER WITNESSING THE WORST
DAY IN MOST PEOPLE'S LIVES.
WHEN WE RESPOND TO THOSE CALLS
WE'RE EXPECTED TO HAVE A NORMAL
RESPONSE TO AN ABNORMAL
SITUATION?
AND BOTTLING THAT LEADS TO SCARS
THAT CANNOT BE.
TAKEN AWAY YOU CAN'T UNSEE WHAT
YOU'VE SEEN YOU CAN'T DESCRIBE --
GUTTURAL CRY OF FATHER WHO JUST
LOST HIS SON.
THAT JUST LIVES WITH YOU AND YOU
CAN'T ON HERE THAT.
THOSE STRESSES OF EVERYDAY LIFE
ON THE JOB.
BUILD UP SCARS AND LEAVE YOU
WITH AN INJURY THAT NEEDS TO BE
TREATED NEEDS TO BE COVERED --
BECAUSE IT IS DIRECTLY RELATABLE
TO THE JOB THAT WE DO AND WE
CAN'T.
STOP DOING OUR JOB AND WE CAN'T
START HAVE IN AN ABNORMAL
RESPONSE TO THOSE ABNORMAL
SITUATIONS.
SO WE NEED OUR HELP FOR OUR
FRONTLINE GUYS.
OUR MEN AND WOMEN ARE BROTHERS
AND SISTERS THAT ARE LIVING WITH
PTS I BECAUSE AS WAS MENTIONED.
THERE ARE MORE FIREFIGHTERS
CHOOSING SUICIDE AS THEIR BEST
OPTION.
THEN THE LINE OF DUTY DEATHS AND
THAT IS NOT.
RIGHT.
WE NEED TO GET TREATMENT AND
CARE FOR OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS GET THEM ACCESS.
AND BUILD THIS INTO OUR WORKERS
COMP -- PRESUMPTIVE BECAUSE
LIVING WITH IT I'M STILL.
GETTING TREATMENT.
UP ON A MONTHLY BASIS BECAUSE I
STILL SEE THOSE CALLS AND STILL
HAVE THOSE -- SCARS ARE LEFT
THAT I'M WITH WITH AFTER.
LEAVING A CALL -- WHERE
SOMEONE'S A?
FAMILY MEMBER PASSED AWAY
UNFORTUNATELY FOR BECAUSE BEEN
FORTUNATE -- EVENTS BUT I WOULD
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK A
SENATOR STERN FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE HEALTH OF OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN A CENTERS GOOD
MORNING -- MY NAME IS TIM THOMAS
I'M A POLICE OFFICER FOR THE
LARGEST POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE.
I'M ALSO A PEER SUPPORT MEMBER
FOR MY DEPARTMENT.
AND I ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OF WORKING -- FOR FOUNDATIONS
THAT DIRECTLY ASSIST BOTH OUR
COMBAT VETERANS OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS SPECIFICALLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
AS THEY MAKE EVERY ATTEMPT TO
TRY NOT TO TAKE THEIR OWN LIVES.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THROUGH MY
WORK.
WITH POLICE OFFICERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BOTH IN MY
DEPARTMENT AND AROUND THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT MENTAL ILLNESS AMONGST LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IS
ABSOLUTELY REAL.
WITHOUT QUESTION IT IS REAL AND
THE CHANCE FOR SUICIDE AMONGST
THOSE NUMBERS.
IS ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE ON A
DAILY BASIS.
AS I WAS LOOKING THROUGH THIS
BILL LIKE I CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION.
THAT REALLY IT'S ABOUT A COUPLE
THINGS IT'S ABOUT NUMBER ONE IS
ABOUT IT.
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE TAKING
CARE OF OUR PEOPLE.
I NUMBER TWO IT'S HELPING US
ASSIST IN OUR MOVEMENT FOR
NATIONAL AWARENESS TO BREAK THIS
DID DIGNA.
THE DEADLY STIGMA THAT'S
ATTACHED TO MENTAL ILLNESS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
FIRST RESPONDERS OF COURSE
THAT'S OUR JOB WE ARRIVE AT THE
SCENE OF SOMETIMES HORRIFIC AND
TRAGIC EVENTS.
AND WE ARE CALLED UPON TO ACT
QUICKLY.
AND MOVE FORWARD.
AS WAS WITNESSED DURING THE THE
FIRES HERE IN CALIFORNIA WERE
BRAVE FIREFIGHTERS MOVED AND
ATTACK THOSE BUYERS HEAD ON
SAVING.
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN PROPERTY AND MORE POORLY
SAVING LIVES.
ARE PARADISE CALIFORNIA WHERE
THOSE LAWS WITH THOSE FIRES
RAGED OUT OF CONTROL OUR BRAVE
FIREFIGHTERS MOVED TOWARD THOSE
FIRES INTO THE CARNAGE THE
WRECKAGE.
AND THE LOSS OF LIFE TO SEE
FIRSTHAND.
AT THE BORDERLINE.
NIGHTCLUB IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA WHEN TRAGEDY STRUCK
AND BULLETS WERE FLYING ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
MOVED TOWARD THOSE BULLETS
[inaudible]
SELFLESSLY.
COURAGEOUSLY RISKING THEIR OWN
LIFE.
AND THE CASE OF SERGEANT HE
LISTS FROM THE VENTURA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT GIVING HIS
OWN LIFE IN ORDER TO SAVE OTHERS.
THIS IS A REAL DEAL THE THINGS
THAT WE SEE ON A DAILY BASIS.
IS NOT NORMAL [inaudible]
AND WE IF WE'RE LUCKY AND WE'RE
GRACED BY GOD WE GET TO GO HOME
AT THE END OF THE NIGHT WE GET
TO KISS OUR FAMILY OR WIFE OR
CHILDREN AND WE SUCCESSFULLY
ONCE AGAIN COMPARTMENTALIZE WHAT
WE'VE GONE THROUGH ON THAT DAY
[inaudible]
THE IMPACT [inaudible]
EMOTIONAL IMPACT [inaudible]
IS PALPABLE.
THE THE MENTAL AND STE TO STRAIN
IS.
COLLABORATIVE A WAY I MEAN IT
WORKS.
THE ROUTE THAT YOU THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS DAY AFTER DAY MONTH
AFTER MONTH YEAR AFTER YEAR.
IT CAN BREAK DOWN EVEN THE
HARDEST THE STRONGEST.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL WHO BECAME A
FRIEND HE WAS MY TRAINING
OFFICER YOUNG IN MY CAREER.
AND THIS GUY WAS A ROBUST STE
JUST MY EIGHTY MANDATE MANTA
MANTA HUNTER OF FISHERMEN AND AN
UNBELIEVABLE POLICE OFFICER AND
MENTOR.
AND THROUGH THE COURSE OF MY
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM WE WERE
ABLE TO GARNER A RELATIONSHIP
AND HE I ASSISTED HIM IN MANY
ISSUES THAT HE WAS HAVING
TROUBLE WITH BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE BEFORE BECOMING A
POLICE OFFICER.
WHAT I WAS NOT ABLE TO DO WAS TO
ASSIST HIM WHEN HE NEEDED HELP
THE MOST?
AND MY FRIEND HIS OWN LIFE.
HE WAS AFRAID. TO REACH OUT FOR
HELP BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA.
HE WAS AFRAID TO REACH OUT FOR
HELP BECAUSE THE CULTURE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ESPECIALLY IN FIRST
RESPOND OR STATES THAT IF YOU
ASK FOR HELP YOU OR YOUR DEEMED
WEEK.
THAT VULNERABILITIES WEAKNESS
WHEN IN FACT IT IS NOT.
EARLY IN MY IN EARLY IN MY
CAREER I RESPONDED TO A TRAFFIC
COLLISION THAT STICKS WITH ME
ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS
[inaudible] TWO FATALITIES. TWO
YOUNG GIRLS.
IN THE BACK OF THAT VEHICLE AS I
RESPOND I CAN SEE THEIR FACE
RIGHT NOW.
HERE TODAY THERE IS ABOUT THE
SAME AGE AS MY DAUGHTERS ARE
TODAY.
AND BECAUSE I'M ABLE.
TO COMPLY COMPARTMENTALIZE A
DEAL WITH THIS.
IN WAYS THAT I'VE LEARNED HOW TO
DO MOST POLICE OFFICERS DON'T
HAVE THAT ABILITY.
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE PRO PRO
ACTIVE LEAGUE FOUND -- THAT
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WERE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO DIE BY SUICIDE.
THEN WHILE IN THE LINE OF DUTY
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
AND THIS BILL IS LESS ABOUT THE
NUMBERS.
AND IT'S MORE ABOUT THE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
AND THIS.
IT'S GOING TO HELP.
DROPPED THE STIGMA.
OF OF OF MENTAL ILLNESS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AS GOING TO HELP THE PEOPLE THAT
DALY HELP US ON EVERY SINGLE DAY.
SAVE OUR LIVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING [inaudible]
YOUR YOUR HISTORY.
REYES OF YOUR LIFE TO OUR VERY
IMPACTFUL SO THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. THREE YEAH MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AARON READ
REPRESENTING CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGH WITH OLEMAN.
A CALIPHATE OR LOCAL TONY EIGHTY
ONE AND POOR HACK -- I'VE BEEN
REPRESENTING LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
OVER FOUR DECADES.
AND I'VE SEEN THIS FRONT AND
CENTER WITH THE MEMBERS AS I
TRAVEL THE STATE I'VE MET WITH
THOUSANDS OF THEM OVER THERE WAS
FORTY YEARS.
AND AS THE WITNESSES ARE ALL
CORRECT
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
MACHO THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
THEIR JOB NEVER COMPLAIN AND BE
INVINCIBLE.
AT AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE
SUICIDE RATES ARE VERY HIGH I
WOULD PATROL HAS HAD OVER A TWO
DOZEN SUICIDES.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS --
SOMETHING WE NEVER TALK ABOUT.
OKAY AND BUT IT'S THERE -- THE
STRESSES OF THE JOBS THE CARNAGE
THAT THEY SEE I WOULD PATROL
USED HAVE A MAGAZINE.
AND THEY WOULD PUBLISH ACCIDENT
PHOTOS AND IT JUST GOT SO
TERRIBLE THEY JUST STOP THE
MAGAZINE.
THEY STILL HAVE TO DO THE PHOTOS
AND WHAT HEY SEE THOSE IMAGES
JUST LIKE HE SAID ABOUT THE KIDS.
IN THAT CASE OF THE HOW TO
OFFICERS THEY SEE THAT ALMOST
EVERY DAY IN THOSE IMAGES NEVER
LEAVE.
PARTICULARLY KIDS.
IT'S SO MUCH SO THAT THE HIGHWAY
PATROL ASSOCIATION ESTABLISHED.
AN ORGANIZATION CALLED IMPACT
TEEN DRIVERS THEY'VE RAISED AND
SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
TRYING TO EDUCATE KIDS ON THE
DANGERS OF DISTRACTED DRIVING.
EVERY BILL THAT'S IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON DISTRACTED
DRIVING HAS BEEN SUPPORTED
BECAUSE THE CARNAGE OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
IS JUST HORRIFIC IN THE SCENES
THAT THEY SEE NEVER LEAVE HIM
CAL FIRE. FOR EXAMPLE THE
PARADISE FIRE.
IF YOU WENT UP THERE IT'S LIKE A
MOONSCAPE.
AND AND THEIR DEAD BODIES AND
THEY SEE THAT AND IT NEVER
LEAVES IT NEVER LEAVES AND THEY
SEE ALL THESE.
THERE WAS A WORST FIRE IN
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THERE'S BEEN IN MANY MANY MORE
ALMOST AS BAD IN YOUR DISTRICT
THERE WERE MANY.
BUYERS -- SAME WITH SANTA ROSA.
ALL OVER THE STATE FRANKLY SO
IT'S IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE IT'S
ONE THAT WE WERE RELUCTANT TO
TALK ABOUT PUBLICLY BUT IT'S
TIME.
IT'S TIME.
SO THANK YOU TO SENATOR STERN
FOR CARRYING THIS MOST IMPORTANT
BILL AND WE'RE PLEASED TO BE CO
SPONSORS THANK YOU TO READ.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE HELLO
AMERICA ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT --
SPIN VERY WELL ARTICULATED
BEFORE ME SO WE CAN KERR AND
SUPPORT THE BILL STRONGLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN.
RESULT IN WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE WORK ON STATE LEVEL
MENTAL HEALTH POLICY WE'RE SO
PLEASED TO ALSO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE -- TO BRING
PARITY TO MENTAL HEALTH COVERAGE
WERE SO ALARMED BY THE THE
SUICIDE RATES.
WE BELIEVE WE MUST BE BETTER AND
WE THANK SENATOR STERN THE
FIREFIGHTERS TO BRING THIS
MATTER FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
A MISTER CHAMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFF'S A TO APPLAUD
THE TREMENDOUS COURAGE THE
WITNESSES HERE TODAY THANK THEM
FOR THEIR SERVICE AND URGENT
EITHER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBER'S NAME ONLY BE DRAWN
WITH MAKE YOU CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
BENEFIT TRUST FUND THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WHICH DUGGAR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ROBERT HARRIS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE -- AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GORDON ALSO WITH THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR RANGER WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING BRIAN RICE PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
IN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THIS
BILL DOES IT IDENTIFIES A MENTAL
HEALTH.
BUT MORE THAN THAT BY
IDENTIFYING IT.
IT GIVES FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS AWAY TO SEEK TREATMENT
FOR IT.
THAT WILL LEAD TO HEALING AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
REALLY WANT TO LEAVE WITH THE
COMMITTEE THAT.
PTS I WITH TREATMENT YOU CAN
HEAL FROM IT.
AND YOU CAN GO BACK TO WORK AND
IT IT IT IS NOT.
A DEATH SENTENCE IT'S A
TREATABLE INJURY AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT I WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH VOTE.
IS SENATOR STERN THANK YOU THANK
YOU COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE NOW IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD [inaudible]
FEELING [inaudible]
TO PLEASE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY -- GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FAITH FOR JUST
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IS WE AGREE WITH THE
AUTHORS RECOGNITION OF THE HONOR
AND DISTINCTION IN WHICH PEACE
OFFICERS SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE RECOGNIZE THE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT THESE
OFFICERS MAY.
ENCOUNTER BUT WE ARE HERE TODAY
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIVE FORTY TWO THE CALIFORNIA
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM
PROVIDES GENEROUS BENEFITS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL WHO WERE
INJURED DURING THE COURSE AND
SCOPE OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
IN THESE BENEFITS INCLUDE
PRESUMPTIONS FOR ILLNESSES LIKE
CANCER AND HEART DISEASE THAT
ARE PRESUMED UNDER LAW TO BE
WORK RELATED WITHOUT ANY NEED
FOR THE EMPLOYEE TO DEMONSTRATE
WORK CAUSATION.
OUR GOAL IS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS IS
TO HELP OUR INJURED EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE EVIDENCE
BASED MEDICAL CARE AND TO HELP
THEM RETURN TO WORK AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TAKE OUR DUTY
SERIOUSLY TO ENSURE THAT ALL
WORKERS HAVE APPROPRIATE
BENEFITS AND COMPENSATION AND WE
ARE AWARE OF NO EVIDENCE THAT
THESE CLAIMS ARE BEING TREATED
UNFAIRLY OR OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LABOR CLOSE.
LABOR CODE WHICH REQUIRES
STATUTES TO BE LIBERALLY
CONSTRUED TO THE BENEFIT OF
INJURED WORKERS.
IN FACT A PRELIMINARY
EXAMINATION OF INTERNAL DATA
INDICATES THAT THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF PSYCHIATRIC CLAIMS
ARE APPROVED.
WE HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN.
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES THAT THE
PSYCHIATRIC INJURY DOES NOT NEED
TO BE PREDOMINATELY CAUSED BY
EMPLOYMENT.
AT ALLOWS NO CONSIDERATION OF
NON INDUSTRIAL FACTORS IT'S
WRECKED YOUR ACTIVE REQUIRING
PUBLIC ENTITIES TO MAKE LARGE
PAYMENTS THAT WERE UNEXPECTED
AND NOT RESERVED.
FOR AN AUTOMATIC ACCEPTANCE OF
CLAIMS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
DENIED.
THE INJURIES ARE NOT LIMITED TO
PTSD AND IT APPLIES TO ANY
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER IT
INCLUDES VOLUNTEERS IT CAN BE
BROUGHT UP TO FIVE YEARS AFTER
EMPLOYMENT.
IT ALLOWS FOR GENEROUS BENEFITS
WITHOUT A MINIMUM DURATION OF
EMPLOYMENT AND WITHOUT
OCCURRENCE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
EVENT.
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO PARTNER
WITH THE AUTHOR IN WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON A BROADER
CONVERSATION ABOUT ELIGIBILITY
THAT EXAMINES THE COST IMPACTS
THAT SUCH CHANGES WOULD HAVE ON
INJURED WORKERS.
AND A LOCAL BUDGETS WHICH ARE
REALITY FOR HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT CONVERSATION BUT AT THIS
TIME WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
VERY MUCH MORNING MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE --
MY NAME'S JASON SCHMELZER WHICH
I GET RANCH WE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND SEE SACK ACCESS
INSURANCE AUTHORITY.
I'M AT THE OUTSET WE MAKE CLEAR
WE HAVE NO ARGUMENT WITH REALITY
I THINK IT'S CLEAR TO EVERYBODY
THAT POLICE AND FIRE BRIEFLY
FACE SOME OF THE MOST HORRIBLE
SITUATIONS THAT OCCUR IN OUR
STATE EVERY DAY -- SOUPS WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO ARGUMENT WITH THAT --
CONTENTION.
I'M ALSO TO SPEAK I REALLY
QUICKLY IF I CAN'T TO THE STIGMA
AND CULTURE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED -- I KNOW MY ASSOCIATIONS
MY CLIENTS TO BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH SENATOR STERN ON ISSUES
SURROUNDING STIGMA AND CULTURE
BUT WITH RESPECT TO SB.
FIVE FORTY TWO AS ABOUT THE
OPERATION OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
KIND OF IN A IN A RATHER MUNDANE
INSURANCE.
TERMS -- SO THAT'S WHERE I WANT
TO FOCUS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT PRESUMPTIONS AND THE
ANALYSIS POINTS THIS OUT ONE OF
THE THINGS WE LIKE TO LOOK AT IS
WHAT IS THE PERFORMANCE OF THE
EXISTING WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM HOW IS THE SYSTEM
TREATING THE WORKERS -- FOR
WHICH THE PRESUMPTION WOULD
APPLY.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE --
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS
SO THOROUGHLY STUDY THERE IS NO
DATA OUT THERE.
THAT WOULD SUGGEST THAT THESE
SPECIFIC TYPES OF CLAIMS FOR
THESE SPECIFIC TYPES OF WORKERS
ARE PROBLEM IN THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM
IF THAT DATA WERE TO ARISE WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO EXAMINE IT AND
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION MORE
CLEARLY BUT TO MY KNOWLEDGE THAT
IT SIMPLY DOES NOT EXIST.
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY BECOMES WHY DO WHY DO
WE CARE WHY DOES IT.
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WAS ALREADY
SAID WHY IS THE DATA MATTER.
AND AGAIN THE THE ANALYSIS DOES
A PRETTY GOOD JOB YOU'RE
POINTING OUT -- SOME KEY FACTORS
THIS REALLY IS -- A DEPARTURE
FROM THE SORT OF GRAND BARGAIN
THAT EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
AGREE TO IT BEGINNING AT THE
SYSTEM IS KIND OF THE
UNDERPINNING OF THE ENTIRE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM THIS
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD THAT WE WE
WE AGREE -- TO AND SECOND THE
THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT
PSYCHIATRIC THAT CURRENT LAW ON
PSYCHIATRIC INJURIES EXISTS --
BECAUSE THERE WAS WELL
DOCUMENTED FRAUD AND THE CLAIMS
ARE A MAJOR COST DRIVER EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE FILED WHEN THE
INJURY WAS LARGELY DUE TO NON
OCCUPATIONAL INJURY.
INJURIES ARE FACTORS AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MATTERS IN THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM THAT
WE NEED TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
TO WE HAVE THE ABILITY VERY
CLEARLY IN THE SYSTEM TO MAKE
DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS -- SOME OF
THE BEST REFORMS THAT WE'VE SEEN
FOR THE TRENDS TOWARDS REFORM
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS HAVE
REALLY BEEN ON EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYEES GETTING TOGETHER.
AND MAKING WISE DECISIONS BASED
ON DATA I THINK WITH RESPECT TO
YOU SB FIVE FORTY TWO WE'D LIKE
TO OPERATE ON THAT SAME LEVEL
WE'D LIKE TO WORK WITH -- THE
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL IN THE
SENATOR -- AND SEE WHERE WE ARE
THERE'S THE COMMISSION ON HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION WHICH IS A JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT -- THE
COMMISSION THEY CAN EVALUATE
THESE ISSUES AND WE'VE
RESPECTFULLY THINK THAT THIS
ISSUE SHOULD BE KEPT THERE FOR
FURTHER EXAMINATION.
I CONSIDERATION BUT AS IT STANDS
RIGHT WE HAVE TO RETURN OF OF
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
COME FORWARD AND MORNING.
GOOD MORNING JOSH DUGGAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND ALSO
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
ALL IN OPPOSED FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE
OF BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR DISCUSSION FROM COMMENTS --
I DID YOU HAVE SOME COMMITTED.
I YOU KNOW IT'S YEAH THIS IS ONE
OF TOSE THE BILL THE FIRST SAID
SENATOR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN.
BRINGING THIS -- THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE FORWARD I YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE I WAS FRANKLY TORN WHEN I
READ THE INTERNET THAN ANALYSIS
AND AND LISTEN TO THIS BECAUSE
THE YOU KNOW WE ASK A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT FROM A PEACE OFFICERS IN
FACT.
YOU KNOW I MEAN THIS IS SUCH A
MINOR THING BUT NOT NOT MINOR
BUT AS I WAS DRIVING IN.
FROM THE BAY AREA ON MONDAY
MORNING I'VE WITNESSED THE
ACCIDENT ON ADDICTION AWARE OF
PERSON GOT OUT OF HIS TRUCK
COULDN'T LOST HIS LADDER AND
FROM A PICKUP.
IT WAS IN THIS THE THE I GUESS
NUMBER THREE LANE OR TWO LANE
AND AND THE FLOW LANE.
HE RAN UP. TO GET THE LETTER AND
HE WAS HIT BY A CAR AND IS I DO
A BY THE EVERYONE WAS TRYING TO
WORK WORK ON HIM ON THE STREET
AND HE DIED.
SO IT'S IT'S IT EVEN AFFECTS.
YOU KNOW A LAYMAN WHO DRIVES BY
AND SEES A BODY ON THE GROUND --
AND HOW THAT BODY IS CONFIGURED
CONTORTED IN IN SOME WAYS IS.
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU DO.
YOU REMEMBER AND IT DOES HAVE IT
CAN HAVE AN EFFECT ON ON ON
ANYONE BUT MUCH LESS WHEN
SOMEONE SEES IT ON  REGULAR
BASIS AND HOW YOU HAVE -- TO YOU
CAN NEVER GET I THINK HARDEN TO
THAT -- AND AND IT IS -- A
TERRIBLE A TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE --
FOR FOR ANYONE AND IN OUR PEACE
OFFICER SHE IT.
FIREFIGHTERS ALL THE TIME -- AND
EVERY DAY -- AND AND GETTING
THAT METAL THOSE MENTAL HEALTH.
RESOURCES TO THEM IS IS CRITICAL
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE BEST
WAY TO DO THAT BUT I DID LEARN
SOMETHING IN THE HEARING TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS.
RELATED.
TO THE ISSUE OF THE PRESUMPTION
DOES.
DO SOMETHING.
TO ALIGN IT WITH.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A POSSIBILITY
THIS IS A A THE AFFECT OF YOUR
PROFESSION THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN COME FROM.
YOUR PROFESSION -- AND THAT IT
IS.
IT'S IT'S NOT AN UNNATURAL FOR
THAT TO OCCUR AND SO I THAT
STIGMA IN IN THE CULTURE CHANGE
I THINK.
I THINK THE PRESUMPTION DOES
MAKE IT.
CAN MAKE IT -- BETTER.
EASIER FOR THEM TO SEEK HELP
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO GET THAT THEY ME
THE PRESUMPTION DOESN'T GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH HELP THEY NEED. TO
DO IT BUT IT MAY ALTER THEIR
CONSCIOUSNESS IN A BILL IT WITH
THE ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD AND
SEEK THAT HELP -- SO I IT IN IN
THE OTHER PART.
WHICH I'M FINE WITH WITH THE
CERTAINLY SUPPORTING THE BILL.
TODAY BUT I'M I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CHANGES IN THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN THERE --
THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS -- AND I THINK
WE CAN LOOK AT THAT -- SOME
CALLING C. BUT THAT'S A CONCERN
THAT.
THAT I HAVE WITH IT AS WELL SO I
THINK IT'S IT'S SOMETHING WE
HAVE -- TO I MEAN THE THE THE
LEGISLATION AND MOVING THE OF
THE PRESUMPTION I THINK IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION [inaudible]
CENTER PAN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR HELL -- JUST I I GUESS
THE BILL -- I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR WORKERS
COMP.
COSTS AND SO FORTH BUT YEAH HI
I'VE SPENT TIME AN EMERGENCY
ROOM.
AND SO IT'S SO I'M SEEING A
FRACTION OF WHAT.
RIGHT AND SOMEONE BROUGHT THE
PATIENT INTO THE ER.
RIGHT.
AND LOT AND SO YOU KNOW SOME
PEOPLE DRIVE THEMSELVES IN BUT
THE ONES WHO ARE REALLY SICK ARE
REALLY INJURED.
RIGHT.
GOT BROUGHT IN BY MEMBERS OF
FIRE SERVICE.
SO THEY SAW WAS LIKE AND FEEL.
THAT'S PRETTY DRAMATIC.
I BELIEVE AT THAT.
I'M OF THE BILL VERY GOOD THANK
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO KNOW FOR THE COMMENTS THE
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE YOUR EXPERTS HERE ON
HOW TO RESOLVE SOME OF THE
ISSUES BUT AS IT WAS SO APTLY
PUT.
IT'S TIME IT'S TIME. TO TO PUT
THIS THIS TYPE OF INJURY ON A
LIST THAT I THINK.
IT CERTAINLY BELONGS ON BREAK
NOW WE PRESUME ABOUT HEART
DISEASE HERNIAS PNEUMONIA
MENINGITIS TUBERCULOSIS.
IT'S TIME TO START TREATING.
MENTAL HEALTH.
ILLNESSES OR YOU HAVE THOSE
INJURIES AS JUSTICE EQUAL TO ANY
OF THOSE OTHER WORKPLACE
INJURIES.
AND FOLKS NEED TO GET PAST THE
FACT THAT THIS IS SOMETHING TO
BE ASHAMED OF AND THAT OUGHT TO
BE HIDDEN.
AND WHAT IT IS TO BE A MAN.
WHAT IS TO BE TOUGH -- THIS IS
THE YEAR TO START CHANGING THAT.
WHILE THE PUBLIC PAYING
ATTENTION SO YOU KNOW.
IT'S NOT JUST THE FIRES IT'S
THOSE WHO GO THROUGH MASS
SHOOTINGS LIKE WE HAD BORDERLINE
WE HAD AN SAN BERNADINO.
THIS IS TOUGH STUFF SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE AND
THIS FORTUNE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN -- WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR AND
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE MOTION
IS DEPRESSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
HILL HI PHIL.
MORRELL [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
WE HAVE BOTH TWO VOTES WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE NO YOU REYES STOOD.
THE TRUTH THANK YOU SIR. ONE ONE
SIX TWO FOUR ONLY COMES.
I'M SORRY THANK YOU WITH
SINESTRO THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB.
SEVEN THREE ZERO PLEASE PROCEED
THIS VERY GOOD THANK YOU --
SWITCHING.
MODES HERE.
THE FUTURE OF WORK IS.
SOMETHING WE'VE ALL BEEN
WRESTLING WITH I THINK FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN THIS STATE
AS THE PACE OF AUTOMATION --
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION STARTS A
CHALLENGE.
OUR SORT OF FUNDAMENTAL NOTIONS
OF WHAT IS WORK AND WHAT IS THE
WORK OF OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN GOING TO BE IN
THIS STATE -- THE FUNDAMENTAL
THESIS IS BILL IS WE JUST DON'T
KNOW WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S COMING.
AND THERE'S A LACK OF DATA AND
SORT OF CLARITY INTO THE NATURE
OF THE PROBLEM AND THE TENSION
POINTS IN THE STATE.
THAT IS THE REASON I BRING THE
BILL BACK AGAIN THIS YEAR WE RAN
SOMETHING SIMILAR LAST YEAR.
AND THE GOVERNOR -- ADOPTED SOME
OF THE ELEMENTS OF THE FRAMEWORK.
STATION NOW -- INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION SO HE'S PUT
TOGETHER A FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION -- WE'RE STILL
WAITING ON WHAT THE DETAILS THAT
ARE BUT PART OF THIS BILL IS HOW
TO HELP SHAPE THAT -- MAKE SURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S PURVIEW
INTO THAT PROCESS MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALSO GETTING ACCESS TO
THAT DATA BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WE DON'T KNOW RIGHT NOW THERE'S
A LOT OF FEAR IN THE WORK FORCE.
WITH OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
LABOR -- WHO ARE CONCERNED WE'RE
CONTRACTIONS ARE GOING TO OCCUR
BUT RIGHT NOW THAT YOU'RE LABOR
STATISTICS AND THOUGH AND THE
WORK WE'RE DOING JUST?
WERE NOT OUT AHEAD OF IT SO
MAKING HE'S DONE SOME AMAZING
WORK GLOBALLY BIG SURVEYS WE
NEED OUR OWN ASSESSMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THIS
COMMISSION IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
BODY TO DO THAT -- AND I THINK
THAT THERE IS SOME MARRIAGE HERE
TO BE HAD WHERE TECH IN LABOR
DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY BE
OPPOSED TO ONE ANOTHER BUT WE
CAN ACTUALLY.
PUT DATA INTO THE SPOTLIGHT AND
TRY TO WORK THROUGH SOME ISSUES --
RATHER THAN SIT IN OUR CAMP SO
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
AYE BENJAMINEDDIE.
HAVE THE MILKEN INSTITUTE SO
THEY'VE BEEN DOING SOME REALLY
INTERESTING WORK -- ON THIS
ISSUE OF CONVENING VARIOUS
CONFERENCES FORM SO WE
APPRECIATE THE BRAIN POWER THE
THE INS TO BE HERE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE AND TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
MILKEN INSTITUTE -- WE AT THE
MILKEN INSTITUTE IS A NONPROFIT
NON PARTISAN THINK TANK WE'VE
GOT LOCATIONS.
I'M CENTERS IN SANTA MONICA AT
LONDON SINGAPORE IN DC JUST SO
THAT WE'RE INSURING WE'RE
CAPTURING THAT NATIONAL AND
GLOBAL PERSPECTIVE ON THESE
TYPES OF ISSUES.
AND WE CERTAINLY DO SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF A STATE COMMISSION
DESIGNED TO CONSIDER THE IMPACT
OF TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER DYNAMICS.
ON THE FUTURE OF WORK ON OUR
CENTER OF REGIONAL -- ECONOMICS
HAS BEEN LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE
FOR VARIOUS YEARS AND WE EVEN
HELD A PANEL ON THIS DURING OUR
CALIFORNIA SUMMIT LAST AUGUST --
BUT AS THE FUTURE WORK TAKE
SHAPE WITH THE AUTOMATION A I N.
AS THERE'S GOING TO BE OBVIOUSLY
A HIGHER DEMAND -- FOR HIGHER
SKILLED WORK FORCE WE BELIEVE
THAT AND THIS WILL HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON THE STATE AND
ON THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND JOBS --
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE'RE
LEVERAGING OUR EXISTING --
PARTNERSHIPS AND CREATING NEW
LINKS FOR INDUSTRY AND EDUCATION
I'M A COMMON THEME THAT HAS BEEN
RESONATING IN OUR WORK IS
FINDING THAT -- WORKERS.
UP SCALING -- WE FOUND THAT
THERE IS AT WORKERS NEED TO BE
EQUIPPED WITH SKILLS FOR
TECHNOLOGY SIMPLE COMPUTER
LITERACY AND ENHANCING
TRADITIONAL SKILLS HAS BEEN
REALLY -- THE FOCUS HERE SEEING
AT GIVEN THE AUTOMATION IS GOING
TO BE IMPACTING ABOUT 40% OF ALL
JOBS THAT WE SEE TODAY BY.
TWENTY FOURTEEN I'M THERE IS
GOING TO BE A NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE SORT OF
PURSUING CONTINUING EDUCATION AS
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO
ACCELERATE.
I'M SO IF WE ARE GOING TO MEET
THIS CHALLENGE IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
BRING ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO GATHER
TO DISCUSS AREAS OF CONCERN AND
ALSO OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLABORATION.
WHICH IS WHY I'M WE ARE SO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS TYPE OF
COMMISSION BEING FORMED AND ALSO
SORT OF THE CONVENING OF UNIX AT
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
REPRESENTATIVE DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
COME.
FOR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COURTNEY
JENSEN ON BEHALF OF TECHNO AND
SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS BILL FOR A RETHINK
THIS BELL AND THE COMPUTER
SCIENCE PACKAGE THAT'S MOVING
THIS YEAR.
KIND OF GO HAND IN HAND TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
WORKFORCE IS PREPARED FOR THE
JOBS OF THE FUTURE AND TO GIVE
CALIFORNIA THE WORK FORCE THAT
IT NEEDS SO -- ASPER I BUILT
THANK THANK YOU MISS GENTIAN
APPRECIATE THAT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE OUT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR SO IT IS [inaudible]
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SO [inaudible] TO SUPPORT --
ZERO COOK.
FOR DRUG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ACTUALLY --
SUPPORT IF AMENDED -- WE FOR
COMING IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE FIT IN THE
ANALYSIS -- WE SUPPORT SO THE
MAIN FACTOR ASSOCIATION.
IN A COALITION OF OTHER FOLKS.
I HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE OF AUTOMATION ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
NOW WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE.
DEALING WITH THAT WE ARE THE
FOLKS THAT ARE NOT ONLY AFFECTED
BY THE CHANGES AND AND HOW THE
WORKPLACE IS FUNCTIONING WERE
ALSO THE MAKERS OF THE DEVICES --
MACHINES AND AND ROBOTS ARE
GOING TO BE CHANGING THE FUTURE
WORK SO WORK.
DIRECTLY IMPACTED WE APPRECIATE
THAT SENATOR STERN IS BRINGING
THIS BILL BACK OF THIS YEAR IT'S
AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION I AND
WHY WE'RE STILL ENGAGING -- IS
BASED ON THE SAME CONVERSATION
THAT WE WERE HAVING LAST YEAR WE
AGREE.
WITH THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
MILLIKAN INSTITUTE IN THAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS NEED TO BE PRESENT
WHEN WE'RE DICUSSING THIS IN
OUR ISSUE NOW IS THAT THE BILL
ONLY IDENTIFIES. ONE POSITION
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHAT WE
KNOW IS THAT THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE AFFECTED
DIFFERENTLY FROM THE RETAIL
INDUSTRY DEFINITIVELY FROM THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY.
AS WELL AS TRANSPORTATION
HEALTHCARE AND ALL THAT SO WE'RE
SAYING IS TO TO GET THE DATA
THAT WE KNOW THE SENDER SIR
WANTS TO HAVE A WE JUST NEED ALL
THOSE FOLKS AT THE TABLE SO.
THAT IS OUR ONLY CONCERN -- AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL IS
BEING BACK WE LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH THE OFFICE.
VERY GOOD I I I APPRECIATE THAT
I THINK YOU'VE MADE A GOOD POINT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OR AS A
MORNING MILITARY MEMBERS MATTHEW
ALL OF WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE WE ALSO HAVE A
SUPPORT OF HIM IN A POSITION THE
BILL FOR THE SAME REASON STATED
REASONS VERY GOOD THANK YOU AT
THE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION AYE AYE I WOULD AGREE
THAT I THINK WE NEED.
TO HAVE THE REPRESENTATION
BECAUSE IT THE DIFFERENT WORK.
FORCE I GOOD FOR INDUSTRIES --
HAVE DIFFERENT CHALLENGES AND
THINGS SO THE WAY IT'S LAID OUT
RIGHT NOW IS IS WHAT IT THE ONLY
SPECIFICITY IN THIS SORT OF
MEMBERSHIP REQUIREMENTS ARE ONE
REP FROM ORGANIZED LABOR AND ONE
REP FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT
IT DOESN'T.
GET GRANULAR BEYOND THAT RIGHT
SO IT'S FOUR MEMBERS FROM THE
GOVERNOR ONE SPEAKER ONE PRO TEM
SECRETARY OF LABOR AND
CONTROLLERS EX OFFICIO.
SO THE ONLY SURE TO CALL OUT SIR
ONE ORGANIZED LABOR WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES AND ONE
PRIVATE SECTOR WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES.
SOME OPEN TO IDEAS BECAUSE WHAT
WE WANT TO GET THE EXPERTISE
THERE TOO SO I'M.
I'M OPEN AT YEAH I'M NOT I'M NOT
QUITE SURE HOW THE MECHANICS OF
IT OUGHT TO WORK.
I MEAN HOW HOW SHE HOW HOW
SPECIFIC WILL BE LIKE WE CALL
OUT AND EGG MANUFACTURING TAKE
AND SORT OF START TO BREAK IT
INTO SENATORS BUT THEN DO WE
MISS SECTORS I DON'T KNOW.
SO WESTERN EUROPE.
YEAH.
COUPLE QUESTIONS SURE BECAUSE
ONE THING I WORRY I THIS IS A
GREAT.
HER GOOD HAN.
WELL GREAT ALSO.
HELLO IT'S GOOD YOU KNOW IT IS
IT THIS IS  BIG INDUSTRY THAT'S
COMING RIGHT BUT I DO WORRY WE
HAVE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED OVERSIGHT
DEPARTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW.
SO IT HOW IS ARE THEY GOING TO
BE PAID [inaudible]
THIS IS.
ARE THESE PAID POSITIONS.
I DIDN'T SEE THE BILL OR WHERE
THEY BECOME A PAID POSITIONS IF.
NOT HOW MUCH IN AND HOW MUCH
WILL IT COST THE STATE.
RIGHT HOW MUCH WORK IS THERE IN
THE FUTURE OF WORK -- THE
COMMISSION SHALL BE ADVISORY
ONLY.
NO WRITER OBLIGATION THE STATE
TEMPERAMENT FINDINGS I GUESS
IT'S YEAH I WOULD IMAGINE.
I DON'T IMAGINE WHO WOULD ASK
THE I WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR GUIDANCE ON THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHEN I'LL GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT WHEN I COULD GIVE
YOU NOT GONNA GIVE ANSWER I
DON'T HAVE -- ASSUME THAT
THERE'S SOME PER DIEM ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT SERVICE.
IN IT DOES GO TO APPROPRIATIONS
SO THEY'LL LOOK AT THE YEAH THE
COST.
AND YOU CAN WORK WITH HIM THE
HOPE HERE CENTER IS THAT.
IF THE GOVERNOR'S ALREADY DOING
THIS AND ALREADY PUTTING
BUDGETARY RESOURCES TOWARDS IT
INTERNALLY THAT WE WANT TO WE
WANT SORT OF SOME LEGISLATIVE
APPOINTEES IN THAT PROCESS OR
WAY TO FORMALIZE IT.
SO THAT'S THE ONCE I GET THOSE
BACK GOOD I'LL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU ON THAT GOOD YOU GOT.
VERY GOOD THE YES AND NO THANK
YOU CENTER STERN FOR BRING THIS --
BILL FOR ANY THIS.
WE NEED TO LOOK STRATEGICALLY
THE NATURE OF THE WORK PLACE AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT AUTOMATION I
MEAN WITH THAT AUTOMATION FOR
AWHILE ACTUALLY BUT WE'VE MOVED
FROM I GUESS I'M NATION FOR
MECHANICAL.
WORK TO NOW AUTOMATION INVOLVING --
OTHER TYPES OF WORKING CUTTING
CERTAIN TYPES OF COGNITIVE WORK
SO WE TALK ABOUT SELF DRIVING
CARS RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST.
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY YOU HAVE
AUTOMATION IN CARS READY BUT YOU
HAVE - SO AND HOW THAT THEN
CAUSES DISPLACEMENT AND WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THAT ALSO THE NATURE
OF THE THE THE WORKPLACE MOVING
FROM SERVE THE OLD INDUSTRIAL
AND ECONOMY WITH THE HELP THE
ASSEMBLY LINE TO A DIFFERENT
KIND OF A COULD.
CALM THE INVOLVING A MUCH MORE --
NO COGNITIVE TYPE WORK ETCETERA
SO APPRECIATE THAT I PRESUME
YOU'RE OPEN TO THE DEVELOPMENT
THE COMPOSITION THE COMMISSION
IT'S ACTUALLY FAIRLY SMALL AND
IT SAYS SIX PEOPLE SO IT'S
POSSIBLE ONE COULD FIGURE YOU
OUGHT TO TRY TO GET REPRESENTS
SOME.
OF THAT SO YOU CAN GET A LITTLE
BROADER REPRESENTATION I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT MOST COMMISSIONS.
YOU KNOW CONFIRM PEOPLE IN THE
STATE SENATE.
THAT'S USUALLY WHAT THAT THEY
SAY AND THAT DAY I THINK MAIN
EXPENSES.
AFTER IT'S NECESSARY TO ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO CARRY OUT THE
COMMISSION'S WORK SO AND I'M
SURE THAT.
YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH THAT WITH
APPROPRIATIONS SO WITH THAT I'D
BE HAPPY TO MOVE TE BILL.
WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AND CERTAIN VERY BRIEFLY
APPRECIATE THINGS THE DISCUSSION
I HOPE WE CAN DIG MORE INTO
THESE DETAILS I MEAN OTHER.
POINTS THIS YEAR SPECIFICALLY
AROUND IS SORT OF NEAR TERM --
ISSUES IN IN THE LABOR -- WORLD
BUT THIS IS STARTED.
TRY TO LOOK AT A HEAD AND BE A
LITTLE BIT. FOR LOOKING SO WE
DON'T RUN INTO CONFLICTS DOWN
THE LINE SO WE CAN ANTICIPATE A
ISSUES YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT
IT'S HARD FOR ROBOT TO FOLD THE
TOWEL OR TO DEAL WITH A A BED
PAN FOR A IN HOME SERVICE --
WORKER AND THAT THEY ARE LESS
VULNERABLE THAN SAY YOU KNOW A
RADIO LIKE A NO RADIOLOGICAL
ASSISTANT DOING SCANS -- IN THE
SYSTEM OF OF X. RAYS YOU KNOW
THESE ARE MICRO -- ANALYSES THAT
WE ACTUALLY NEED SO WE CAN GET
OUT AHEAD OF THINGS AND
HOPEFULLY PREPARE WORKFORCE FOR
A FUTURE WHERE WE HAVE WORK.
SO WITH THAT RESPECT YES FOR AYE
BOTH DQ SENATOR STERN -- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM CENTER AND
AND IN THIS DOES GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS YES AND AND IT
DOES GOOD GEO I BELIEVE I THINK
WE'RE DOUBLE REFERRED TO GEO AND
WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS HAS TO REMAIN
ORGANIZATION.
SENATOR HILL HI I'M MORAL
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
PAN ALL RIGHT.
I WE HAVE TO A TWO AND WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OVER FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF WE DO HAVE A
CONSENT ITEMS IF OF HAVE A A
MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THIS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
AND ITEM NUMBER TEN SB. SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR HILL HI.
I'M AROUND.
MORRELL AYE JACKSON.
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE PAN.
I WAS IN THE FOURTH IS THAT THE
THE HAS FOUR VOTES END OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
WE WILL NOW -- GO DOWN -- THE IN
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
THREE SIXTY TWO SENATOR ROSS THE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
MORRELL NO. THREE LOADS OF THAT --
BILL IS OUT -- WILL MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB FOUR THIRTY BY
SENATOR WHITE CASKEY A PLEASE
CALL THE AFTER MEMBERS SENATOR
MORALE HI [inaudible]
WROTE HI. THREE THE BILL HAS
THREE VOTE IT IS OUT -- I
REMEMBER FOR SENATOR A GALGIANI.
SB FIVE THIRTY PLEASE CALL YES
YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
MORRELL.
JACKSON.
OF MORALE HI.
MORRELL I FOUR VOTES THAT BILL
IS OUT -- ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR HILL
USUALLY AFTER MEMBERS.
MORRELL.
HI MORRELL AYE JACKSON.
AS FOR VOTE THIS BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR BREAUX
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL ALL RIGHT MITCHELL I
DON'T HAS THREE VOTES THE IT IS
OUT -- ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR MONEY
PLEASE CALL THE AFTERMATH.
JACKSON OFF NOW MORRELL NOW.
THREE OF THREE VOTES IT IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER -- NINE SB.
SEVEN THIRTY IT'S SENATOR STERN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR MORALE [inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL HI THE
HOST THREE VOTE IT IS OUT AND
WE'VE COMPLETE THAT COMPLETES
THE BUSINESS.
OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU ALL AND THIS A HEARING
IS ADJOURNED